انه يوم لن ينساه تلاميذ هذه المدرسه
الخاصه في جنوب غرب فرنسا عند الساعه
العاشره صباحا وجه طالب بالغ من العمر 16
عاما طعنه قاتله لاستادته بعد الاعتداء
حجره تلاميذه على مدى ساعتين في صفوفهم
قبل ان يخرجوا منها ظهرا طلاب الصف الاول
الثانوي الذين كانوا في الفصل مع المعلمه
عندما قتلت لازالوا تحت صدمه ما وقع
في فصل اللغه الاسبانيه كان كل شيء يسير
بشكل طبيعي حتى قام تلميذ وطعن المدرسه
بسكين كبير في صدرها
لاحظت انه كان هادئا عندما طعن المعلمه
لا اصدق حقا ما حدث لم اكن اتوقع يوما
النساء اكون شاهده على هذا النوع من
الحوادث
الضحيه كانت مدرسه للغه الاسبانيه وبلغ من
العمر 52 عاما بحسب مصدر مطلع على القضيه
فان منفذ الهجوم لديه اضطرابات نفسيه اذ
قال للمحققين انه يسمع اصواتا غريبه فور
وقوع الهجوم توجه وزير التربيه الفرنسيه
الى سان جونغوليوز حيث وقع الحدث
ستلتزم المدارس في جميع انحاء فرنسا
بدقيقه صمت
هذا يوم حزين للتربيه الوطنيه
ويوم حزين لهذه المدرسه
الصدمه اثارت موجه ردود فعل سياسيه واسعه
بدءا بالرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون
وصولا الى اليمين المتطرف ومرورا باليمين
واليسار والوسط